a number of online retailers have posted  product pages for witcher 3 wild hunt  enhanced edition but if that's something  you like the sound of you may not want  to get your hopes up just yet neogaf  uncovered listings the unannounced came  from European retailers in Leclerc and  smart toys who claimed the new edition  would be arriving on playstation 4 xbox  one and pc in early fabric Witcher 3  developers that a project read had not  announced enhanced edition of the game  although they have released enhanced  editions of the two previous witcha  games marketing lead me helpless of  caliphs cute responded to the appearance  of the listings on twitter by saying  there's no enhanced edition of the  witcher 3 wild hood that we're aware of  this is some kind of error that we will  look into let me know down in that  comment box if you'd be keen to play an  enhanced edition off the witcher 3 and  stay tuned to GameSpot's for all the  latest